You know that there is one thing that could prevent you
from voting in the European elections in June,
it would be to be registered in the wrong polling station.
Is that what we call being misguided?
And among 18 and 25 year olds,
it concerns 4 out of 10 voters.
More frequent is 1 student who left his parents' home but who remained registered
on the electoral list of his or her home town.
To check if you are registered in the city where you live,
it's very simple,
you have to go to a public service.
Point.
FR,
you inform your name,
your date of birth,
the name of your commune.
And the answer is almost obvious to change the polling station.
Again,
it's very fast,
you fill out 1 form and add 1 proof of residence and your identity
document and then it's your city hall that will contact you
directly to confirm your registration.
Be careful not to wait too long for the deadline to make the steps
online and to be able to vote in the European elections,
it is May 1st.
And don't forget to note in your agenda the date of this European election,
it will be the next 8 and 09/06.